네. 안녕하세요. 빌사남입니다. 어,
제가 오늘은 최근에 외국인 분들이
한국 부동산을 좀 많이 매입을 하고
있습니다. 외국인 보유 주택수가
10만원을 돌파했고 그중에 절반이
중국인들이 매입을 했습니다. 그래서
원래 중국인들이 인천이나 이런 경기도
외곽 지역의 부동산을 주로 매입하다가
최근에는 서울시에 되게 유명한 고가
주택을 많이 매입하기 시작을
했습니다.이 이 외국인 투자자가
늘어날 시기는 98년도에
외국인들이 투자할 수 있게끔 문을 좀
열어 줬어요. 그래서 원래 기존의
허가제였다가 이걸 시군제로 변경하면서
그때부터 외국 자본들이 좀 많이
들어오기 시작을 했습니다. 그리고
본격적으로 들어온 시기는
2020년도부터
그러니까 이제 코로나 시작할 때부터
본격적으로 외국자분들이 폭발적으로
많이 늘어나기 시작했고 문제가 뭐냐면
자금 출처가 되게 불명합니다.
아무래도 외국에 자본이 있다 보니까
이게 돈이 어디서 흘러왔는지 자금
출가 좀 어려워요. 국내 사람들은
매입할 때 자금 조달 계획서를
쓰거든요.이 돈이 어디서 났는지 뭐
대출을 받았는지 뭐 주식을 팔았다는지
뭐 이런 내용들이 다 있는데
외국인들이 이걸 추적하기 좀
어렵습니다. 그렇다 보니까 세금에
대한 좀 이슈가 많았어요. 뭐 만약에
뭐 2주택자, 3주택자일 경우에는 막
이렇게 취득세 중가 요건도 있고
그리고 이제 보유세도 국내 사람들은
뭐 종합부동산세라든지
뭐 기존 세율들을 좀 되게 높게
내는데 외국인들은 일단은 자금 출처를
조사하기가 되게 어렵습니다. 그
대표적으로 최근에 92년생 그래서이
중국인이 성북동에 있는 단독 주택을
125억에 매입을 했습니다. 어이
성북동 자체가 원래 시세 차이가
그렇게 큰 곳이 아니에요. 그리고
이제 보통 실거주 목적으로 많이
매입을 하는데 원래 기존에 있던
매도인이 2014년도에 50억 원에
매입한 주택입니다. 선북동 시색 차익
중에 정말 이례적인 사례라고 생각할
정도로 되게 많은 차익을 남기고 어
매각한 그런 사례라고 보시면 될 거
같아요. 우리 심지어 매입할 때
대출을 하나도 받지 않았습니다. 저는
현금으로 좀 매입했고 두 번째 사례
말씀드리면 88년생이 타워 팰리스
팬트하우스를 89억 원에 매입을
했습니다. 자금 조달 계획서를 봤는데
중국에서 전액 대출을 받았다라는
내용으로 좀 썼다라고 합니다. 중국
같은 경우에는 우리나라랑 이런 주택
담보 대출 한도라든지 이런게 좀
다르잖아요. 어 우리는 뭐 LTV도
있고 뭐 DSR도 있고 뭐 대출
규제가 되게 심한데 중국은 상대적으로
뭐 정확히는 모르겠지만 대출 규제가
더 완화적일 수도 있거든요. 그래서
외국인이 우리나라 부동산을 투자할 때
어 되게 매력적인 거 같아요. 본인
나라에서 대출을 최대한 받아서 매입을
할 수 있기 때문에 매입한 사례 중에
또 하나가 2017년도에 여기 삼성동
아이파크 팬트하우스를 러시아 사업가가
매입을 했습니다. 105억 정도에
매입을 했는데 신기해서 되게 유심히
봤던 사례입니다. 외국인이 한국
분홍산을 투자한 거를 뭐 대략적으로
좀 알고 있었지만 빙산의 일각일 수도
있어요. 예를 들어서 뭐
반포자이라든지
뭐 저기 원밸리라든지 뭐 이런
대표적인 아파트 단지도 한번 전수
조사해 보면 다양한 나라의 외국인이
좀 많이 매입한 사례가 있지 않을까
싶습니다. 지금 외국인들이 매입하는데
문제가 뭐냐면 금액대가 큰 부동산
같은 경우에는 이렇게 최고가로 매입을
해요. 고급 아파트들을 계속 최고가를
경신하게 이렇게 매입을 합니다.
그래서 실제로 호주 같은 경우에는
외국인들이이 호주 부동산을 많이
매입하다 보니까 외국인이 투자를 못
하게 이렇게 막아놨다라고 합니다.
최근에. 근데 우리나라 아직까지 그런
상황이 되진 않지만 최근에 법안도 좀
발휘되고 외국인이 한국 부동산을 매
못하게 법안들을 좀 많이 마련을
했다라고 하는데 어찌됐든 이렇게
최고가를 계속 경신하다 보면
외국인들이 계속 시장을 끌어올려서
가열 분위기를 좀 많이 만들 수
있다라고 생각을 합니다. 그리고 국내
사람들이랑 어떻게 보면 차별화가
있잖아요. 어, 국내 사람들은 대출
규제도 되게 심하고 뭐 세금 이슈도
되게 크고 자금 출처 계획도 되게
심하게 하는데 외국인 같은 경우에는
비거주자로서 그렇게 심하지 않거든요.
인기 있는 부동산들이 어떻게 보면
글로벌 부동산화의 초입에 들어왔다라고
생각을 합니다. 그래서 뭐 기존에
저희가 뉴욕 갔었을 때도 외국인들이
굉장히 좀 뉴욕 부동산을 많이
투자했거든요. 그리고 최근에는 뭐
카타르 자금도 많이 들어와 가지고
부동산 가격이 많이 올랐는데이
외국인들이 어떤 부동산에 투자하고
있는지도 되게 유심히 보실 필요가
있는 거 같아요. 그래서 앞으로 더이
외국 자본들이 어이 부동산 시장을
많이 이제 자지우지 할 거라고도
생각을 합니다. 그런 부분도 좀 관심
있게 보셨으면 좋겠고 아무래도이 국내
사람이 매입하는 거보다는 조금
불평등한 부분도 있기 때문에 이거는
빨리 법안이 처리가 돼서 외국인이나
국내 사람들이 좀 이렇게 형평성 있게
어 부동산 투자를 할 수 있게끔 어
되었으면 좋겠습니다. 최근에 이제
서울 부동산 가격들이 진짜 엄청 많이
오르고 있거든요. 이렇게 외국인들까지
부동산 투자에 같이 참여하고 있다
보니까 정말 많이 과열화 돼 있는 거
같습니다.네 네. 그래서 오늘은
외국인이 한국 부동산 투자하는 사례를
가지고 좀 얘기를 했는데 뭐 최근에
이제 새로운 정부도 들어오고 막
기사만 보면은 계속 최고가 경신하고
있다라고 하고 외국인들 계속 사고
있다라고 하고 되게 불안정한 시장인
거 같은데 어떻게 보면은 좀 진통을
겪고 있는 식인 거 같아요. 한국의
서울 그리고 이제 이런 고가 부동산이
어떻게 보면 외국인들한테 어느 정도
매력이 있으니까 이제 이분들이 투자를
한 거잖아요. 되게 뭔가 글로벌화되고
있다라고 저는 생각을 합니다. 그래서
되게 혼란스러운 상황인데 외국인들이
어떤 부동산에 투자하고 있는지도
여러분들이 아셔야지 나중에 부동산을
어디에 투자할 건지가 정해지는 거
같습니다. 그래서 오늘 영상은
여기까지 하고요. 다음 시간에 뵙도록
하겠습니다. 감사합니다.
[음악]